so a capital allocator explain
what that job is in the world and do you
have any i was thinking about this today
when i was in the shower i was like
where did this concept of capital
allocators even originate from i
we know about carrie and that when you
know ships used to go to the
uh what was then called the orient uh or
to india to get
spice or whatever somebody would say hey
listen if you get the package back here
i'll give you 20
of whatever makes it back to shore you
get carry you get a portion of what
comes back
and that aligned interest so we know
that piece where did the concept of a
capital allocator even come from
yeah i think it's relatively new um if i
go back i started my career in 1992
and just to give you a perspective at
the time there were no more than a half
a dozen of these offices in the country
and i think i was the only junior
analyst
looking at funds in the entire country
like yale used to hire one undergrad a
year
and so harvard had an office but they
were mostly direct investing and
stanford had an office but there were
four or five
you know senior people they're very very
few of them um
the reason i think it's come to pass has
kind of goes hand in hand with the
notion of modern portfolio theory
in that if you have a large pool of
capital and you're trying to
preserve and grow it for a long period
of time
[Music]
and they're spending needs along the way
people have adopted the notion that you
want to be diversified
and so the question is if you were four
or five people
you know maybe it was 10 or 12 back then
and a little more today but you're four
or five people sitting in new haven
connecticut
and you want to diversify around the
world you have two options right one is
you could say okay
let's go figure out how to compete with
jason and all the other seed stage
venture capitalists and we'll compete
with sequoia
and then let's go to asia and we'll pick
chinese stocks and oh by the way we
probably want to be in large cap and
small cap stocks in the u.s and equity
and credit oh we need expertise in the
bond markets
at some point time your head starts
spinning and say well we can do one of
two things we can either try to compete
with an increasingly specialized world
or we can just go try to identify them
let's develop our skill set to try to
identify the best and partner with them
and so that that became a model that
went hand in hand with this kind of
strategy
and really got popularized when david
swenson wrote his kind of seminal
book called portfolio pioneering
portfolio management in 2000 and then
you started to see proliferation
of more of these offices and and more
lps in these strategies
and so the the clear path to becoming a
capital allocator at one of these
endowments was to have been an alumni
of that place for some reason is that
correct i mean i suppose right
one of the things that's interesting
about my show is when i interview a
bunch of these cios there is no clear
path
because the fact is the industry didn't
exist 20 years ago so how could you have
been trained in it
ah yes that makes total sense it's like
asking for somebody to be
like a an ar developer it's like or you
know
an ai developer well yeah i speak
systems now for 30 years but yes people
were like
i need a iphone app developer for
with five years experience when the app
store had just came out people would put
up
exactly ads for that it doesn't make any
sense
so